okay everybody i'm so excited for our
scream week here on the drew barrymore
show and right now we have none other
than the newest scream queen jenna
ortega who's coming back to the show and
we're so lucky to have her although for
this i thought i would send somebody
special in for the assignment
hello jenna hi ghostface drew's a little
tied up at the moment so i'll be
interviewing you i love it i'm going to
ask you the final five the extremely
final five great
first question you're in a scary movie
but what scares you the most i'm
terrified of the ocean like
there's dinosaurs in there that may be
large groups of people running not like
a marathon
if i was on walking on the street and i
just saw a bunch of people running i
probably would start running with them
what was your favorite scream behind the
scenes memory i think the relationship
that i formed with the cast because i
mean it's been over a year since we shot
the film and we still consistently talk
on group chats i've never experienced
anything like it before i think that the
movie just came at a really special time
with a really special group of people
and it really did feel like magic and um
i don't know i love them all dearly we
know you've seen a ghost face
but have you ever seen a ghost i don't
think i've actually ever seen a ghost
but when i was younger i used to swear
that i saw things all the time i would
tell my mom that there was
a girl my age in my house or like
children jumping up and down my hallway
are you scared jenna
no
what was the last lie you told other
than that one i was hanging out with my
cast mate hunter and i told him that i
fissy
weddings
and that i did that for my brother and
to this day he believes it he's getting
married he's engaged and i said hey if
you need someone let me know and that
was a complete lie i just thought it was
funny and finally
what's the scariest thing about you i
think my humor i can get really dark
really fast and
it's kind of spontaneous and i think
that that might intimidate people
sometimes thanks jenna you really killed
those questions thank you so much
ghostface you are in a much better mood
than the last time i saw you
ghostface
scooch over drew hi hi jenna so nice to
see you how did ghostface do he did
great okay good because you deserve the
very best and i'm so honored that you
would come back on our show and we just
love you so much thank you very much
drew see you soon we love you
thanks ghost face thank you ghost face
bye jenna see you later oh god i hope
not
no offense
[Music]
you